now thank you for joining us here at
noon i'm christian casadis a grocery
store in the southeast valley closed the
front awning collapsed with customers
and workers inside this happened around
6 30 this morning now take a look there
on your screen it happened at la bonita
supermarkets at desert inn and eastern
where investigators are now trying to
figure out what went wrong four people
rushed to the hospital let's check in
with hector mejia he's live there at the
scene and hector what have you found out
about the collapse
well i talked with the president of the
grocery store chain who tells me that
two employees and one customer are among
the four people heard out here and just
take a look at the scenes that make you
think of a war zone investigators from
clark county here now trying to figure
out why the front awning here at this la
bonita supermarkets grocery store
location
crumbled out here we can see heavy
wooden beams
piles of debris scattered from the front
entrance out to a couple of parking
spots
like a bunch of water just falling on
top of each other stacking just
friday around 6 18 a.m moments of chaos
at la bonita supermarkets the awning out
front collapsed just as employees were
opening for the day near eastern ndi
four people suffered
non-life-threatening injuries everyone
left in disbelief there wasn't any sign
it just
suddenly just fell i recorded you could
hear in the record over
over my voice some people calling out
for help adolfo navarrete says he was
outside drinking coffee during his break
when he heard the rattling of windows i
was literally just about to go back in
if i was five seconds earlier to hang up
the phone and go in i would have been
caught up under that
so when i get home i'm just gonna light
we were in the car listening to the
radio talking i was taking them i was
taking the kids to school you see the
smoke the water shooting out the side of
the building
people were running from the building it
was crazy investigators are now trying
to figure out what went wrong
it's hard to say that we have the
building department out here they'll
check that out
back out here you can see the building
has been red tagged no one allowed
inside so with the store closed the
employee we talked with told us they
might get sent to other locations in the
meantime until they're able to reopen
this location reporting near eastern ndi
hector mejia 8 news now